bonjour à tous point précis d'abord pour
commencer ce progrès sur l'agenda
l'agenda du mouvement de l'est
républicain donc avec un déplacement
aujourd'hui de son président nicolas
sarkozy à amiens un déplacement qui sera
consacrée à la thématique de la chasse
demain aura lieu vous le savez la
matinée de travail sur l'environnement
et l'énergie sujet particulièrement
d'actualité et nous aurons à 18 heures
un bureau politique
enfin mercredi jeudi et vendredi le
président nicolas sarkozy se rendra au
chili et en argentine
concernant notre journée de demain
je voudrais revenir donc sur ce sujet
puisque ce sera une réunion importante
je le disais sur l'environnement et
l'écologie le président nicolas sarkozy
lors de son interview dans le jdd a
rappelé son positionnement
particulièrement en matière de politique
sur le nucléaire et en matière de
d'énergie vous dire que dans cette
actualité justement environnementale la
porte parole des verts a rappelé qu'il
n'y avait pas d' espaces pour l'écologie
avec françois hollande nous ce que nous
disons c'est qu'il y a de la place pour
l'écologie à droite une écologie
pragmatique que d'écologie responsable
et une écologie qui place le citoyen au
dessus des normes
c'est cette écologie là que nous voulons
défendre si cette écologie là que nous
présenterons justement demain à lors de
cette matinée une écologie bien loin de
l'écologie punitive tels que la doctrine
la gauche met donc une écologie
responsable lors de cette bâtisse de
travail il y aura trois tables rondes la
première sera consacrée à la mer la
deuxième sera consacré à la politique
environnementale dans son ensemble et la
troisième sera consacré à la politique
énergétique dans la vie du mouvement
également je voudrais vous signaler la
nomination de deux nouveaux
secrétaires nationaux louis
devient secrétaire national aux
transports et jean spiri devient
secrétaire national à la prévention
santé de la jeunesse sur l'actualité
politique avant que guillaume larrivé
eric ciotti e détails les événements du
week end particulièrement sur l'aspect
de la sécurité
je voudrais vous dire qu en tant qu élu
de paris
je n'arrive pas évidemment à m'habituer
à la situation de ce que nous
connaissons maintenant non seulement
place de la république
mais place de la nation ou sur paris
dans son ensemble le gouvernement
maintenant depuis plusieurs jours mais
je devrais peut-être dire plusieurs nus
jouent avec le feu et n'a pas fait
preuve d'autorité en temps et heure
il a laissé s'installer des conditions
d'une rébellion
laissant le mouvement nuit debout
squatter la place de la république
malgré les débordements puis les
affrontements il appartient donc pour
nous au gouvernement mais également aux
responsables des différentes
manifestations et aux responsables des
différents mouvements de tout mettre en
oeuvre pour que ce dangereux engrenage
qui porte en lui le vent de la révolte
sociale soit tout simplement stoppé par
ailleurs nous dénonçons avec force le
climat de haine qui est en train de
s'installer à l'égard de nos policiers à
qui nous voulons aujourd'hui à nouveau
apporter notre soutien
entre une loi travail qui a été vidée de
son sens mais qui pour autant d'ailleurs
vous l'avez remarqué n'aura donc pas
calmer les revendications syndicales et
celle des frondeurs une droite on le
sait qu'ils s'apprêtent à ne pas la
voter puisque dans son écriture première
il y avait en effet des convergences
il appartient évidemment maintenant au
parlement de se prononcer mais nous
savons que l'écriture telle qu'elle se
précise fait que le gouvernement n'aura
pas donc sa majorité
et quand la pression ne cesse de monter
nous demandons donc au gouvernement
comment il compte encore
longtemps comme cela comment avec un
gouvernement déstabiliser et un
président discréditer nous allons
pouvoir continuer à travailler ensemble
ici pour l'intérêt des français un point
sur la journée de refondation de l'école
et vous dire comment nous nous étonnons
en effet de ces deux journées qui sont
prévus dans ce climat actuel les
journées de la refondation de l'école
qui s'ouvre aujourd'hui sont pour nous
tout simplement une opération
électoraliste qui ne cherche d'ailleurs
même pas à dissimuler cette intention
politique
la manipulation est grossière et ne
trompe personne
en effet comment ne pas se rappeler de
cette réforme des rythmes scolaires dont
les parents et les enseignants
d'ailleurs avait dit tout le mal de ce
qu'ils ont pensé réforme qui était mal
ajusté et coûteuses et dont nous payons
j'allais dire encore le prix maintenant
qui avait été d'ailleurs de surcroît
décidé autoritairement et puis aussi
cette réforme des collèges qui avaient
révulsé les enseignants qui l'avait
d'ailleurs massivement rejetée et avait
essayé de faire comprendre à ce
gouvernement
combien elle était contestable et enfin
donc nous constatons la l'urgence de ce
gouvernement de récupérer un électorat
qui était en train de lui échapper
et c'est donc la politique du chéquier
que nous retrouvons aujourd'hui
ici comme ailleurs la semaine dernière
cela avait déjà été dénoncé par
guillaume larrivé plusieurs milliards
déjà à l'actif donc de françois hollande
depuis le début de l'année cette
politique du chéquier qui donc se
confirme aujourd'hui avec une nouvelle
mesure a l'intention même si elle peut
être justifiée des enseignants du
primaire et la nécessité à ce qu'il y
ait de contrepartie
nous demandons donc nous les
républicains un compteur nous allons
donc d'ailleurs l'installer le compteur
des dépenses de monsieur hollande depuis
le début de l'année c'est cadeau c
chèque remis à chaque catégorie sociale
depuis maintenant plusieurs mois en vue
tout simplement de sa réélection
je passe maintenant la parole à
guillaume larrivé eric ciotti pour un
apport complémentaire sur la sécurité
merci brigitte avant la sécurité un mot
sur l'actualité parlementaire immédiate
puisque demain à l'assemblée nationale
nous allons entamer la discussion du
projet de loi sur le travail
ce sera un moment de vérité les députés
républicains et notamment isabelle le
callennec et gérard cherpion mais
l'ensemble des députés républicains nous
allons tester au fond la volonté du
gouvernement et de la majorité de
réformer ou non pour de vrai le marché
du travail et donc nous allons engager
le débat sur des amendements très
concret très précis très opérationnels
sur lequels sur lesquels il y aura bien
sûr un vote j'en citerai trois trois
principaux nous voulons débattre de la
suppression du compte pénibilité parce
qu'au fond notre job à nous à
l'assemblée nationale ce sera de faire
entendre la voix du bon sens et
notamment la voie des pme qui créent des
emplois et qui n'aspire qu'à pouvoir
travailler conquérir des marchés sans
entraves réglementaire excessivement
nous tenons à débattre de la suppression
du compte pénibilité premier amendement
phare deuxième amendement fars nous
tenons et ça ne coûte rien aux finances
publiques a supprimé ces fameuses effets
de seuil qui sont totalement destructeur
d'emplois je pense notamment au seuil de
11 qui doit être relevé à 21 pour le
délégué du personnel au seuil de 50
nous souhaitons relever à 100 pour les
délégués syndicaux les cee les chsct
sont des sujets très concrets
on connaît tous dans nos
circonscriptions des entreprises qui ont
48 49 salariés et qui rechignent à
embaucher un 50e salariés qu'il en
ferait franchir ce seuil
ça ne coûte rien aux finances publiques
il suffit d'un vote de l'assemblée
nationale pour déverrouiller ces effets
de seuil
et c'est un débat qu'il faut absolument
voir à l'assemblée troisième
amendement clé que je souhaite vous
présenter au nom des républicains ce
matin c'est ce qui concerne le barème
des indemnités prud'homale il nous
paraît tout à fait nécessaire qu'un
barème d'indemnités contraignant et pas
seulement indicatif soit adoptée par par
le parlement il y aura bien sûr d'autres
amendements qui concerne notamment le
temps de travail et d'autre et d'autres
questions
nous savons qui a probablement pas de
majorité pour voter ces amendements de
bon sens mais précisément il faut que ce
soit un exercice de vérité
bas les masques au delà des au delà des
discours on entre dans un moment où il y
aura la vérité des votes sur cette loi
sur cette loi travail ce sera donc très
très important de voir qui sera
véritablement du côté de l'emploi des
pme des salariés et qui sera au
contraire du côté des rigidités et des
complications
on attend donc ce débat avec ardeur il
ya plus de cinq mille amendements qui
ont été déposées à l'assemblée nationale
ce sera donc un débat tout à fait
passionnant vous aurez noté que le
gouvernement la semaine dernière on
avait un peu parlé partie du
gouvernement a tenu une espèce de
meetings pour en réalité
se parler à lui même la gauche se
regarde le nombril et se dit à elle même
et au la gauche
bon nous avons le sentiment que les
français eux ont envie de dire ciao la
gauche font et c'est à d'où évidemment
de donner un contenu à cette aspiration
c'est pour ça que les républicains
continuent à travailler semaine après
semaine sur ces conventions sur ces
éléments de programmes qui feront qu'au
mois de juin juillet on aura ici un
projet d'alternance très novateur sous
l'impulsion de nicolas sarkozy par un
projet mou pas un projet ni de gauche ni
de droite et de gauche et de droite
un projet de droite qui s'assume comme
telle qui veut rompre avec l'immobilisme
de françois hollande et qui refuse tout
autant l'illusion mariniste à ce propos
un mode actualité sur ce à quoi on a
assisté hier le front national 7 enfermé
dans une sorte de fronde familial avec
des images qui rend bien compte de la
réalité de de ce mouvement très très
incertain en réalité quant à ça quant à
sa ligne quant à sa ligne politique
comme un élément mois que j'ai retenu du
du discours de la présidente du front
national c'est cette espèce donné au
communisme économique qui serait
complètement contraire aux besoins des
entreprises le marinisme est un néo
communisme économique beaucoup plus
proche d'ailleurs du programme actuel de
jean luc mélenchon de ce qui était le
programme de jean-marie le pen dans des
années dans les années passées
ce programme néo communistes du front
national
serait absolument dramatique pour pour
l'économie française
je pense naturellement aux erreurs de
politique monétaire qui sont proposés
par marine le pen
mais aussi à son fiscalisme sa volonté
de rigidifier le marché du travail à sa
volonté de bureaucratiser l'économie
française avec des schémas économiques
qui sont complètement ringard et qu'il
serait complètement contre-productif
je crois qu'on a aussi le devoir de le
de le dire
après vous avoir parlé de la loi comme
riz et de ces quelques éléments
d'actualité
économique et parlementaires avec un ex
petit on va revenir sur les questions de
de sécurité avant qu'eric ne complète je
veux dire comme comme parlementaire ma
préoccupation devant les incohérences du
gouvernement
il est quand même extravagant que le
premier ministre nous demande de
prolonger l'application de l'état
d'urgence d'un côté tout en assumant pas
de l'autre côté
l'exercice de ses pouvoirs de police
administrative
il ya là une incohérence hiatus et même
une sorte de schizophrénie peut pas d'un
côté avec des coups de menton
sollicitée la prolongation de l'état
d'urgence et de l'autre refusé d'exercer
vraiment les pouvoirs de l'état de droit
l'état de droit ça n'est pas un sujet de
colloques l'état de droit ce n'est pas
un slogan l'état de droit ce sont des
instruments d'action publique qui
permettent d'assurer l'ordre public bien
chaque jour chaque nuit on a la
démonstration de ce que l'état de droit
en réalité piétiné par des minorités
agissantes sans que l'autorité de l'état
ne s'exerce pour rétablir véritablement
l'état de droit et là il ya une
contradiction dont le gouvernement doit
sortir dans l'intérêt de la france et
avec eric ciotti et d'autres collègues
parlementaires
nous n'allons pas lâcher bernard
cazeneuve jean jacques urvoas et manuel
valls dans les jours et dans les
semaines à venir
au delà de la communication il faut de
l'action et l'état d'urgence ça ne doit
pas être encore une fois un prétexte de
communication j'ajoute qu'à l'heure où
nous vous parlons nous ne connaissons
toujours pas le calendrier d'examen de
la loi prorogeant l'application de
l'état d'urgence et qu'il faut vraiment
donc sortir des discours entrer dans les
actes et surtout dans la gestion
opérationnelle des désordres que la
france connaît chaque jour sont des
désordres totalement inacceptable
brigitte l'a dit on a une pensée pour
ces policiers
ces gendarmes des forces mobiles qui ont
été blessés qui sont très courageux mais
qui ne sont pas commandés
voilà le problème c'est la chaîne de
commandement la chaîne de commandement
gouvernementale la chaîne de
commandement intermédiaire aussi sans
doute
je pense notamment à la manière dont la
préfecture de police vers les événements
depuis quelques semaines c'est
techniquement tout ça assez incertain
est en tout cas c'est peut assumer
voilà je m'arrête là eric ciotti va vous
en dire beaucoup plus sur ces questions
qui nous passionne évidemment parce que
sont au coeur de ce que doit être l'état
merci guillaume merci à brigitte pas
beaucoup plus mais naturellement dans le
même sens
nous assistons depuis maintenant plus
d'un mois dans notre pays à une
situation totalement inédite et
totalement paradoxal
nous sommes convient de le rappeler
guillaume larrivé en situation d'état
d'urgence en situation d'état d'urgence
deux fois voté par le parlement
parce que la france est confrontée à une
menace terroriste maximale et parmi les
dispositions essentielles de l'état
d'urgence réside la capacité du ministre
de l'intérieur par l'intermédiaire des
préfets à interdire des manifestations
or depuis un mois place de la république
à paris
dans beaucoup de villes de province se
développe des manifestations qui
aujourd'hui ne prêtent plus que le
visage de la violence au départ ce
mouvement se voulait intellectuelle
idéologique mon enfant il est
aujourd'hui l'expression d'une violence
haineuse gratuite et qui ne se réduit
plus qu'à son expression violente
les révolutionnaires de nuit debout avec
les organisateurs masqué avec leur
gourou occulte ceux qui ont droit à une
chaise alors que les autres ne peuvent
s'exprimer que debout comme monsieur
frédéric lordon qui manifestement est la
référence de ce mouvement ont choisi
manifestement leurs références
historiques dans la révolution
pour eux c'est immédiatement la terreur
on voit leurs propos et on est encore
que dans le discours d'une extrême
violence lui aussi mais encore ne pas
juger du fond on à le combattre
naturellement dans notre famille
politique celle des républicains
attachés aux valeurs démocratiques
entendre prôner la révocation des élus
entendent reprenait a mis son discours
de haine contre les médias
c'est déjà une forme de tyrannie mais ce
qui se passe va bien au delà c'est
l'expression d'une violence gratuite je
rappellerai que depuis un mois
plus de 400 policiers ont été blessés
quatre cents policiers ont été blessés
cette expression de la violence
mobilisent chaque nuit plusieurs
milliers de forces de l'ordre que ce
soit des unités mobiles de la
gendarmerie nationale ou des compagnies
républicaines de sécurité
est ce que cela est compatible avec
l'état d'urgence très clairement non
nous demandons au gouvernement d'assumer
ses responsabilité d'interdire ces
manifestations de violence d'interdire
s'est rappelé à ces rassemblements
répétitif et de faire en sorte que
l'autorité républicaine s'applique
désormais le gouvernement fait preuve
d'une mansuétude coupable à l'égard de
nuit debout il fait preuve d'une
complaisance même voire d'une complicité
on ne peut pas à la fois dans les
discours dénoncer la violence et
soutenir les policiers et dans les actes
ne rien faire alors qu'on a tous les
outils juridiques pour prendre les
dispositions qui empêcherait ces
violences ne pas endiguer ces violences
donc il y a une fois de plus une
hypocrisie d'ambiguïté un double langage
de la part du gouvernement
qui par sony inaction favorise
l'expression de la violence donc il faut
que cela cesse il faut que cela s'arrête
nous le disons solennellement et nous
leur dirons à l'assemblée nationale nuit
debout est incompatible avec la
situation d'état d'urgence qui elle même
est exigée par la menace terroriste donc
il faut savoir ce que l'on veut défendre
les principes républicains
c'est aujourd'hui s'opposer à
l'expression de la violence gratuite
elle qu'elle est exprimée par lui debout
voilà ce que nous voulons dire très
solennellement aujourd'hui le mouvement
nuit debout est devenu incompatible avec
la protection de ceux qui nous protègent
nos policiers est devenu incompatible
avec la situation de l'état d'urgence
rendu nécessaire par la menace des roms
je me permets un complément l'objection
juridique qui opposait bernard cazeneuve
à notre demande d'interdiction de nuit
debout
cette objection juridique ne tient pas
lorsqu'on est en état d'urgence c'est
que le parlement a considéré que la
nation devait faire face à je cite une
situation de péril imminent
c'est le critère juridique de l'état
d'urgence nous considérons que cette
situation de péril imminent justifie au
plan juridique des restrictions à la
liberté de manifester et un arrêté qui
interdirait un arrêté du préfet de
police de paris qui interdirait
l'occupation de la place de la
république par nuit debout serait
certainement susceptible d'être
contestée devant le tribunal
administratif de paris mais cette
contestation
elle nécessiterait bien évidemment que
le ministère de l'intérieur se défendent
et il ya de nombreux arguments
juridiques pour légitimer aujourd'hui
compte tenu des troubles qui ont été
constatés compte tenu de la nécessité
pour les forces mobiles de se concentrer
sur d'autres sujets de protection de la
nation
on voit bien qu un arrêté d'interdiction
de nuit debout serait parfaitement
fondées en droit bernard cazeneuve a
tort de soulever sur cette question
précise
une objection juridique qui comme on dit
en droit qu'elle n'est pas dire immonde
c'est pas un obstacle
on peut y avoir un débat juridique ça
normal contestation d'une tribu ministre
hâtif ensuite devant le conseil d'état
mais nous considérons que le
gouvernement doit assumer pleinement ses
responsabilités et aux plans politique
et au plan juridique
les deux sont liés